- I would like to
introduce Alicia Martin.
Alicia received
her PhD in genetics
from Stanford University
and is currently
working as a research fellow
at the Broad Institute.
She is a population and
statistical geneticist.
And she's very much interested
in how human migration impacts
health and traits.
So Alicia, I'm keeping
the intro short
because there's a lot
of interest here today.
So I want the speakers to speak.
And I want you all
to ask questions.
[APPLAUSE]
- Hi, everyone.
So I want to start by thanking
the organizers both for giving
me the vertical assistance
here and for inviting
me to talk to you guys about
genetic prediction of traits
and diseases across
globally-diverse populations.
So I'm one of the
local scientists here.
I work primarily at Mass
General Hospital and the Broad
Institute.
So first to get started, I
want to start with some very
fundamental basic facts.
So you've all heard that
human genomes are about 99.9%
identical.
And this is absolutely the case.
There's very few sites
on the relative scale
of the entire genome that vary.
However, that said, the
genome is really, really big.
It's greater than 3
billion base pairs,
which means there's
still about four to five
and a half million sites
that vary across the genome,
depending on which
population you're from.
And every one of your
billions of cells in your body
has all of these different
variants because they have
the exact same copies of DNA.
When we're trying to
understand the human genome,
it's also important to recognize
that this heritable variation,
these genetic
differences, account
for a lot of physical and
biomedical differences
across these populations.
So looking, for example,
at physical differences
across populations,
you can easily
recognize that height and skin
color and many other traits
are visibly different
across these populations.
And a lot of that is due
to fundamental genetic
differences.
Additionally, we can think of
different classes of traits.
So we can think of single gene
traits, very simple traits,
for example, like your ability
to digest the sugar and milk
lactose, your eye
color for example,
and whether or not you have
the disease cystic fibrosis.
But most traits are much
more complex than this.
They're actually
driven by many genes
across a genome or many
variants across a genome,
maybe tens of thousands,
maybe hundreds of thousands.
It's still not entirely
clear how many genes
are contributing to some traits.
But these are the
kind of the traits
that we're going to be most
interested in talking about
for today.
So these include things
like height, weight,
or many different kinds
of complex diseases.
So when we think
about our genetic risk
of different diseases and
our genetic complex trait
distributions, we have
to think about two things
simultaneously.
We have to think about
the environment--
so our environmental
distribution here--
together with our
genetic effects--
so a genetic effect
distribution here
across an entire population.
And for each of these, we have
a point in this distribution.
And if we knew
these perfectly, we
might be able to know
exactly, for example,
what one phenotype would
look like-- for example,
exactly how tall you might be.
But it's also important
to note that we
can use this type of model
to think about binary traits.
So we can also think about,
for example, whether or not
you're going to have a
heart attack by using
the same kinds of models.
So instead of thinking about
this continuous distribution
here, we might draw a
line in this distribution
called a liability threshold.
And we might say that above
this liability threshold,
you're likely to
have a heart attack.
And below this threshold,
you're not likely
to have a heart attack, say,
over the course of the next 10
years.
So let's try to make these
models a little bit more
concrete and think about
the translation of genetics
into potentially precision
medicine moving forward.
So the first place that I want
to talk about for genetics
is that this is really
not deterministic.
Our genes are only
one part of the story.
And the environment makes up
a big proportion of the story.
Additionally, traits are
quite variable in how
heritable they are.
So there is this nature
versus nurture difference
between many different traits.
So for some traits, there's
quite a bit of heritability.
So you might think of height,
for example, or schizophrenia,
where knowing a lot
about your family
tells you quite a bit about
how tall you're going to be
or how likely you are to have
schizophrenia when you grow up.
However, there are a lot of
traits that you can probably
think of that are not very
heritable, such as how
likely you are to
vote for any given
candidate in a political
election, for example,
or some factors that geneticists
are studying like how
likely you are to develop PTSD.
It's also important to note that
polygenic risk scores give us
sort of a prediction at
an individual level that's
only accounting for these
genetic differences.
So we're not getting any
proxy for environment.
So throughout this, just
keep that caveat in mind.
So coming back to thinking
about this in translation,
heart disease is
one aspect that I
think is going to be really
important in the relatively
near future for thinking
about polygenic risk scores
as cardiovascular
researchers are really
trying to push this most
rapidly into health care.
So the first study that
I want to talk about
is the Framingham Heart Study.
So this was conducted
using thousands
of participants over the
span of the last few decades.
And one of the most
important findings from this
was a cardiovascular
disease risk
model, which is used in
health care all over today.
So this includes a lot of
factors like age, sex, LDL
and HDL cholesterol,
your blood pressure,
if you have high blood
pressure, whether or not
you're being treated for
hypertension, whether or not
you have diabetes, and
if you're smoking or not.
One finding from the study
is that if you smoke,
you have increased
risk of heart disease.
But notably from
this model, there's
actually no genetic information.
The researchers
perhaps could have
used something
like family history
as a proxy for
some genetic data.
But our genetic data
actually gives us
a very nice granular
level of insight
that we can't necessarily
learn from our family history
alone because our family
history is a little imprecise.
It's also important to note
that there are differences
in monogenic factors
and polygenic factors
also at play for
some complex diseases
even like heart attack risk.
So we know that
polygenic factors
account for more risk
across the entire population
than monogenic factors.
So for example, having
a greater than threefold
risk of cardiovascular
disease is 20 times more
likely to be driven by polygenic
factors than single genes
alone.
So a recent study of polygenic
risk in cardiovascular disease
has really made a
lot of headlines.
And I think it's really started
to push the needle for what
we can potentially do in the
future for genetic risk scores
in clinical practice.
So as an example from this
study, in this chart here,
you can see on the
x-axis polygenic score
and the prevalence of
cardiovascular disease
on the y-axis.
And so you can see
here that there's
a relationship
between these two,
where there's a
direct relationship.
Having a higher
polygenic score indicates
having higher risk of
cardiovascular disease.
But this relationship
is non-linear.
So if you have a polygenic score
for cardiovascular disease,
not everyone is going
to have high risk
of cardiovascular disease.
And in fact, it's only going
to be those individuals
with the most extreme risk that
stand to potentially benefit
from having this kind
of genetic information.
And then looking at
the entire population,
we can start to make this more
concrete with some numbers
here.
So for example, about
8% of the population
is at greater than
threefold risk
of cardiovascular disease based
on their genetic score alone.
And about 2.3% of
the population is
at greater than fourfold risk.
And about 0.5% of
the population is
at greater than fivefold risk.
So this gives us really
fine scale information
and adds potentially
new information
to cardiovascular disease
models that's not necessarily
captured by things like your age
or your sex or your cholesterol
levels.
So the, I think,
place that we're going
is sort of towards
clinical translational
with a lot of these
polygenic scores.
So these are starting to
become really ubiquitous.
In the All of Us
Research Program spun out
of the Precision
Medicine Initiative,
this initiative is a
nationwide research program
that's designed to collect a
million diverse participants.
And it's designed to collect
individual level biological
and environmental information.
And genetics plays a cornerstone
to that biological translation
piece.
Additionally, there are
direct-to-consumer companies
like Color Genomics and
23andMe that are already
starting to give polygenic
scores out to their customers,
in 23andMes case, to their
millions of consumers.
So some of you in this room
might also already have access
to a polygenic risk score,
for example, for your BMI.
Color Genomics is giving
out polygenic scores
to their consumers for heritable
risk of some types of cancers.
And I think the cardiovascular
field has really
made the biggest push to
translate this into the clinic.
So this quote that
I've put on this slide
here comes from a perspective
based on the previous study
that I mentioned in the last
slide, which says "we propose
the time has come to
incorporate genetic risk
scores into clinical practice."
And I think there's a lot of
valid points for the enthusiasm
here.
So I think it's a good time to
start having this conversation.
Some of those points
include the fact
that a lot of previous
criticisms for genetic studies
were simply due to limited
sample sizes and limited power,
which is no longer the case for
a ton of biomedical phenotypes
today.
Additionally, those are
relatively cheap tests.
So having a genetic test
done costs about $50
for the array to be run itself.
And that gives you insights
from birth about your risk
of many different traits.
So you can learn, for
example, about your risk
of type 2 diabetes, your
heritable risk of some types
of cancer, for
psychiatric disorders,
for some immune diseases.
And I can't think of a single
biomarker that gives you
as much information about so
many different types of traits.
Additionally, a
doctor would never
consider a polygenic
score on its own.
You can think of this as sort
of an integrative biomarker
that you would consider
alongside many other factors--
for example, your
lifestyle, your diet,
how much you exercise, and
in the cardiovascular disease
case, what your LDL and
HDL cholesterol are.
So with those ideas
in mind, I also
want to turn to the
explosion in human genetics
that's been happening lately.
So looking at this plot,
this starts back from 2006
and goes to present day.
And on the y-axis, we have
the number of individuals
in these genetic studies.
And you can see that these
have expanded massively.
So there are now millions of
individuals regularly partaking
in genetic studies.
So this has grown
totally enormously.
And this has sort
of been spawned
on by the completion
of the Human Genome
Project around the
year 2000, which
drove an entire industry
of genome technology
to develop really much cheaper
genetic testing technologies.
However, the picture, if we
look at this, now colored
by population, is
really not very diverse.
So genetic studies are
vastly Eurocentric.
So this growth has been
overwhelmingly white.
And now I'm showing you the
same exact picture as before.
But I'm also now juxtaposing
it with a global population
here in billions.
And so you can see that
the red population,
the European populations,
make up about 80%
of participants in
genetic studies,
contrasting with only about
16% of the global population.
So this is a major
potential issue.
Additionally here, if we
look at the bottom fraction
here, talking about this speaks
to the fraction of participants
in these genetic studies.
These are overwhelmingly
European participants,
of course.
But there's a troubling sort
of outlook for this diversity
here.
So the troubling outlook
is that since about 2014,
the progress in
diversifying efforts
has been somewhat stalled.
And we're starting
to see a decline
in the diverse proportion
of genetic studies.
So additionally, I think
it's potentially also worth
pointing out that there were
some valid reasons for trying
to include relatively
homogeneous participants
in genetic studies for
some statistical reasons.
For example, having quite
a bit more diversity
in genetic studies is
more likely to lead
to false positive findings
in genetic studies
or some confounded results.
Additionally, the study
funders, of course, in genetics
tend to overwhelmingly be from
Europe and in the US, which
have more of a Eurocentric
population than outside
of those continents.
However, of course, these
funders, even from the US,
this picture looks
non-representative.
So looking at the US, about
60% of participants living here
are non-Hispanic
white participants.
And we're not making
up even a proportion
of the African-American or
Hispanic Latino citizens here.
So the bulk of my work
focuses on this question,
how do bias genetic studies
from an ancestry perspective
impact the generalizability
of knowledge
that we're learning
from these studies?
So I want to be clear
that biology is biology.
If I look at anybody
in this room,
the fundamental basis
of genetic disease
or the fundamental
basis of these traits
is the same no
matter who you are.
And so the reason that we're
having some difficulties
potentially with some
of these genetic studies
is due to genetic correlation,
not because of genetic causes.
So if we knew the fundamental
genetic cause of disease,
that would by and large
translate very well
across diverse populations.
But because of
population history
and because of differences
in correlation structure
and because our genetic studies
are primarily picking up
correlations rather
than causation,
we have potential issues with
how well our genetic studies
are going to
translate, especially
outside of European
descent populations.
So coming back to a map
similar to some of the work
that Sriram showed,
we need to think
about human evolutionary
history to understand
how well these genetic
differences are
going to be reflected across
the span of global diversity.
So as Sriram mentioned,
humans originated in Africa
and then migrated out of Africa
about 50,000 to 100,000 years
ago.
They took a subset of
diversity with them
when they migrated
out of Africa.
This is called a founder effect.
And then migrating out of
Africa, many of our ancestors
moved into Europe
and into Melanesia
and then later into East
Asia and the Americas,
each time taking a subset of
genetic diversity with them.
So this human history
is really important
for thinking about our
genetic differences
and what this means
for predicting
risk of different diseases or
predicting complex phenotypes.
So to bring human history and
trait prediction together,
one of the studies
that I took on
was trying to think about
how polygenic scores or how
polygenic prediction would
perform across a globally
diverse set of individuals.
So applying polygenic prediction
to the 1,000 Genomes Project,
which is a large study with
genomes across very large,
globally diverse set of groups,
we looked at polygenics scores
for height, which
you might think
would be a pretty
simple trait to study.
So from our study,
what you can see
is that we predicted
European populations
to be taller than Americans
and South Asian populations.
And we predicted East Asians
and African populations
to be the shortest.
And it's not just
that we predicted them
to be a little bit shorter.
We predicted African
populations to be
about five standard
deviations shorter
than European populations.
So just to put some
empirical numbers on,
this if a European man is, on
average, about five feet nine
inches tall and a
standard deviation there
is about three inches, if
we applied these differences
in Africa, that would
mean that we would predict
the average male to be about
four and a half feet tall,
or about yea high, which
I already needed a stage
to help me raise me vertically.
So clearly, that's not in
line with reality here.
And that indicates that we
have some pretty big problems
if we're trying to
translate these scores
and think about
cross-population analyses.
So thinking about
this in another way,
one of my colleagues,
Robert Maier,
conducted the same
type of analysis
with much more
granular populations.
So here is a global map showing
what height prediction would
look like in a global context
for many different populations
using, again, the
giant consortium study.
So this study is aptly named.
This study combined
height and genetic data
across hundreds of
thousands of individuals.
And the biological
findings fundamentally
are still quite valid.
But if we try to construct
a genetic prediction
score across all these
diverse populations,
you recapitulate
what I had seen,
which is that in
Africa and East Asia,
we predict these populations
to be shorter than anywhere
else in the globe.
However, if we turn to
a different data source
to build these polygenic
predictions, namely
the UK Biobank, we see
a different finding.
So the UK Biobank, I just
want to mention a little bit
about it.
It's this very large study
that was conducted rally
rather homogeneously.
So it's all conducted in the UK.
And all individuals were
phenotyped at the same time.
So everyone had their height
measured all at the same time.
All samples used the exact
same collection criteria.
And additionally,
population stratification
was accounted for more
thoroughly and consistently
within the study.
So what you can see quite
visibly and easily here
is that we don't predict any
populations to necessarily
be taller or shorter.
But we also know that
this is out of step
with what we see globally,
where we actually
do see some populations that are
taller or shorter than others,
and that perhaps some of
this is due to genetics.
So this really indicates
that our methods
for comparing populations
through polygenic studies
are really totally inadequate.
I would challenge anyone who
would say otherwise right now.
But I would also say
that perhaps this would
be a useful technology even
if we can't necessarily
compare across populations,
because just knowing
your score within a
population can still
have some biomedical value.
If I am, for example, an
individual of European descent
and I know that my
risk is much higher
for some complex disease, I can
still potentially act on that,
as can anyone else.
So combining these
questions, how transferable
is polygenic prediction, keeping
a lot of these factors in mind,
we assess how well polygenic
prediction transferred
across populations by looking
at a bunch of previous studies
that had compared
polygenic score accuracy.
So these studies
combine polygenic scores
that had used the largest
existing data to compute
accuracy within
European populations
and in non-European populations.
And because they were using
the largest studies set
available to them, this means
they were overwhelmingly
using European genetic studies.
So they looked at a
wide array of traits.
They looked at schizophrenia.
They looked at BMI,
educational attainment.
And they looked at height.
And what they found is that
relative to European accuracy,
East Asian accuracy
or East Asian risk
was predicted about less
than half as accurately as
in European populations.
Additionally, when they
looked at African-American
populations, they saw that risk
was predicted a little less
than a quarter as accurately.
So these are really
truly staggering numbers
if we're trying to
think about translating
polygenic risk to the clinic.
Can you imagine, for
example, if you had,
across all drugs, that
they worked about four
to fivefold better in
European populations
than in African-American
populations?
This would be a huge issue.
It's also notable, I think,
that this is a big problem
to address because polygenic
risk scores have the potential
to improve health
outcomes for everybody,
not just European
populations, if we
can start to really
address these problems.
For example, we could
think about using
this as a biomarker for
psychiatric disorders, where
there actually are no biomarkers
that are really easily
accessible today because of
the inaccessibility of brain
tissue.
Additionally, this could
help potentially bring down
the cost of clinical trials
by enabling drug companies
to target individuals at
higher risk and a higher
biological likelihood
of having some event.
So there is a pretty
predictable basis
of these staggering
genetic risk disparities.
So we know in theory
and simulation
and now empirically that
prediction accuracy decays
as a function of genetic
divergence between the study
population and the population
we're predicting in.
This is simply due to
population history.
And if we look at where
humans originated in Africa,
we would estimate
that because of how
diverged they are from
European populations,
we would predict the worst
in African populations
compared to elsewhere based on
where our bias studies exist.
This is partially because
genetic studies are best
powered to discover
common variants.
So if we're studying European
populations over and over
again, we're missing some of
the low-hanging discoveries
in non-European populations.
Additionally, we're
identifying correlations
in our genetic studies,
not causal variance.
And the correlation
structure of the genome
differs depending on
your population history.
And then there are more
complicated differences,
like environment and
natural selection.
So if I'm trying to predict
using a healthy cohort
into a disease cohort,
there are going
to be some challenges because
of environmental differences
there.
So how do we make progress
towards parity now?
We need a lot of big approaches
for these challenging problems.
So I think one problem that
my colleagues and I are really
working to move the
needle on is developing
new statistical methods that
consider this correlation
structure within
and between pairs
of globally-diverse populations.
And I have a lot of hope
that our statistical methods
are going to help us
make some inroads.
But there's going to be
additional problems, I think,
in that our predictions
are only going
to be as good as our data.
So this is a big problem.
It's really going to require
having more diverse large scale
datasets.
So this needs to come
from funding sources
from the top down basically.
And we need to ensure
that data access is
equitable across
pairs of populations.
We also need to ensure
that existing GWAS summary
statistics or
genetic studies are
available across a more
diverse set of participants
and that we have incremental
releases for diverse studies.
And then we also need capacity
building for global regions
that are newer to
genetic analysis as well.
So I'll stop there and
thank you for listening.
And I'm happy to take questions.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you for a
really fascinating talk.
You're probably familiar
with the technique
of Mendelian randomization.
- Closer to the mic, please.
We can't hear you back here.
- One inch from the mic.
- One inch from the
mic-- how's that?
So I was asking about
the technique that's
used in causal inference of
Mendelian randomization, where
genetic traits and
their random assortment
are used to make inference
about, for example, exposures
and disease and the
likelihood of the disease.
How does this issue of lack of
data from certain populations
affect that kind of
inference in particular?
- Yeah.
That's a good question.
So Mendelian randomization
is a great tool
for detecting causal variance
in genetic analysis and causal
relationships between
pairs of phenotypes.
So it would be great
if we could uncover
the fundamental causal variance
for prediction analysis
because that would take away
a lot of this correlation
not causation issue.
Unfortunately,
Mendelian randomization
also requires that you
have a really, really
strong, precise
instrument for uncovering
those causal relationships.
And the vast majority of
our genetic instrument
are relatively weak effects that
we're not really confident in.
So Mendelian
randomization is going
to be a really important
tool for understanding
the causal relationships
between pairs of traits
but not necessarily for
building more useful predictors.
Does that make sense?
- I have a question, Alicia.
So I can share in the
enthusiasm to want
to bring these prediction
kits to the market.
But are we getting a little
ahead of ourselves in terms of
are we outpacing the clinic?
We want to bring
them to the clinic.
But we're outpacing.
How will they impact
clinical management?
I mean, clearly we're outpacing
the treatment options.
So I wanted to know if you can--
- Yeah, absolutely--
that's a great question.
And it's a really great point.
So I think genetics
in general is not
super useful for clinical
translation today.
But I wouldn't necessarily
bet against human genetics
over the course of
the coming decade.
So I think it's important to
start thinking about it now.
Because we've seen over the
course of the past decade
that our studies have gone from
being hundreds of individuals
at a time being studied to now
even millions of individuals
being studied at a time.
So I think it's sort
of a matter of time
before this is
clinically translated.
And I think to head off
some of these issues,
we really need to
think about them
now if we're trying to make
sure that we have equitable
translation and don't exacerbate
existing health disparities.
- OK.
Yes?
- Thanks.
Quick question-- these GWAS
studies have been around
for a few years.
And the earlier studies
were shorter read length
and much more expensive.
The first one cost $3 billion.
So obviously, the
disparities issue--
have you ever tried to quantify
what it would cost to catch up?
So the tests are much,
much cheaper now.
And you can do a
whole genome scan
for what it costs you a lot
more to do even a partial exome.
So if you put a number on it,
maybe somebody would donate.
- That's a really good question.
And it's a really good point.
One thing that we're
trying to think of
is what the costs of
these health disparities
would potentially translate to.
But I think your
question is more
about what would it take
to even these burdens
and generally do these
studies at as large a scale
and many different phenotypes?
So I it depends on which
phenotype you're looking at.
Like if you're looking
at schizophrenia,
let's say, the largest
European cohorts currently
have 150,000
participants, about half
of those of which are cases
and half of which are controls.
So 150,000 individuals at about
$50 a genotyping array plus
some analytical costs, it's
a hugely expensive problem.
But I think we need to start
pushing the needle forward
to be including these.
- And the very last question.
- I love genetics.
But your first slide
started out with
environmental contributions
and genetic contributions.
So how are you going to deal
with the fact that some things,
it doesn't matter what you do?
Your genes are your genes.
But other things,
you know, you haven't
accounted for the
environmental aspects,
especially in things that are
going into precision medicine.
- Yeah.
That's a great point as well.
So I wanted to make
sure that the point was
very clear that genetics
is not deterministic.
So especially for a lot of
these much more complex traits,
there is always
something you can
do to tweak your
environment to reduce
your risk of overall disease.
For the traits that
are not super genetic,
I don't think genetic
risk scores are really
going to add that much value
to a clinical translational.
It's more the traits that
do have a pretty significant
heritable component
that we're going to make
the most inroads clinically.
- Perfect.
Thank you, Alicia.
[APPLAUSE]